your favorite superhero may be able to
deflect bullets
but can they draw in the energy from
every living creature on earth
fuse it all into a giant ball of energy
and chuck it at a bubblegum colored
maniac threatening to destroy our entire
planet
the moment you feel certain about your
grasp of power levels in dragon ball
prepare to have that certainty slip
through your fingers as each character
continues their ascension to glory
whether it be stepping into the
hyperbolic time chamber for a few days
to train for a few years
or a synchronized dance with a companion
to merge into a more powerful super
being
each new development in the series has
shown that there are countless ways to
amplify power levels
over 30 years of lore has created plenty
of ammo for each side of any argument
for that reason let's narrow things down
a bit
there are many powerful characters
throughout the show but we want to stick
with the best of the best
to a point it's understandable that we
would leave zeno the omni king
off the list not only because he doesn't
fight but also because the supreme ruler
of our entire multiverse who can blink
gods
mortals and an entire universe out of
existence in an instant
would make for a boring anticlimactic
finish to an
otherwise juicy debate dragon ball super
contains major players from across an
expansive multiverse
but a majority of the series takes place
in universe 7 where the z
fighters reside on earth other universes
are home to powerful warriors as well
such as the pride troopers of universe
11 excluding numerous fusions
and reducing any transformations to
their core character has resulted in
this completely comprehensive list that
will in no way enrage
any fans of the phenomenal anime series
onward
new villains crop up in dragon ball z
with every new arc
each confrontation forces our heroes to
push themselves beyond known limits
to the point that some characters have
become nigh godlike in power
but there's one being whose immense
power challenges even the strongest
fighters
cell this bioandroid has spent years
obliterating every opponent thrown at
him he's so powerful
that writers had to introduce different
timelines in order for him to be
defeated
even then he manages to take control of
time and travel backwards to make
himself even stronger
cell was created by a supercomputer
using cells from some of the universe's
strongest heroes
he's able to increase his power by
draining energy from other entities
which is why he roams the earth drinking
up the life forces of entire cities
i owe it all to this worthless planet
for providing me with the bio extract i
needed
cell is without question one of the
strongest life forms in existence
the only reason for him being at the
bottom of this list is because of his
recent absence in the dragon ball z
storyline
fans haven't seen cell since gt when
he's briefly allied with another villain
and defeated by goku
but gt isn't considered part of the
canon cell's power has not grown in
quite some time
but given his uniquely adaptive powers
he shouldn't ever be counted out for
good
this lean green fighting machine
originally trained to become one of the
supreme kai's of universe 10.
this is my apprentice the supreme kai in
training zamasu
it is a pleasure to make your
acquaintance
he is well respected among the other
kais for his superior intellect
and massive knowledge base plus he can
brew a mean cup of tea
now you might disagree with zamasu's
ranking on this list but remember
we're talking about the character's core
forms all the scenarios that led to
zamasu becoming insanely unbeatable
are created by his dragon ball wish plus
things don't get completely out of hand
until he merges with goku black
things get so nuts zeno the omni king
has to literally wipe the entire
universe in order to cancel out zamasu's
invincibility
zamasu's misguided sense of universal
justice is the most imposing thing about
him
he views humanity as detrimental to
existence and seeks to wipe it out
his dragon ball wished for immortality
plus his merging with goku black
transformed him into a massive ethereal
entity which envelops the universe
yet at his core zamasu isn't too tough
goku easily defeats zamasu in combat in
his base form
and trunks later slices him in half by
embodying all of humanity and his sword
granted that slice unleashes an
unbeatable cosmic being that begins
raining destruction on the entire fabric
of reality
but hey we say he cheated it might be
the way his soothing lavender hair flaps
in the wind
it may be a stylish jean jacket whatever
the reason
trunks has been a fan favorite for
decades he first appears as a mysterious
young boy
capable of transforming into a super
saiyan we later learn that he is the
offspring of vegeta and bulma
she's my mom
and has traversed several timelines
before settling into the one we know
today
his father's cocky arrogant demeanor is
tempered by his mother's humanity
resulting in a cool level-headed warrior
ranking trunks power level is
complicated given his time traveling
nature
we've seen future trunks achieve
greatness but the main storyline
currently features trunks as a young
playful kid he also tends to implement a
right place
right time fighting technique that
dazzles but doesn't display much
sustainability
the promise of future trunks places him
on a pedestal among fans
one he deserves but all these competing
factors make us reluctant to place him
anywhere but just below legendary status
trunks is no slouch he has helped the
gang defeat cell
beat the tar out of frieza and slice an
immortal in half
trunks is entirely worthy of the praise
he receives but we're still waiting for
more
the tournament of power mashes several
universes together
among those are the saiyans of universe
6 where kale is their version of the
legendary super saiyan
kale shows up at the tournament of power
as a meek timid fighter
paired with her mentor caulifla after
goku enrages her
kale reveals her true power by
transforming into the legendary super
saiyan
kale is so powerful that she marches
unharmed through a kamehameha attack
from super saiyan blue goku
and then unleashes a barrage of
uncontrolled energy blasts at
everyone in the vicinity much like her
universe 7 counterpart broly
kale's base power level is seemingly
limitless
the downside to this genetic trait is
that her form is a berserker state
rooted in rage and difficult to control
the normally docile kale has yet to
undergo the years of training we've seen
other heroes go through
so as of right now kale is all promise
she hasn't had enough time for her
character to develop
but we'll likely see kale rise through
the ranks to become one of the strongest
characters in all of the dragon ball
franchise
[Music]
for a long time broly technically wasn't
considered part of the dragon ball
cannon
thankfully fans latched on to their
favorite rage monster and never let go
in 2018 dragon ball super broly was
released
officially bringing this outrageously
strong character into the cannon
broly was born in a pod next to goku on
the saiyan home planet
his power was so great that it scared
king vegeta who ordered broly and his
father executed
this decision stoked the primal fury now
synonymous with his legendary bloodline
broly's tragic path in life leaves him
devoid of any appropriate training for
his immense power when faced with
challenges
broly simply calls forth more power and
bashes the problem in with his fists
his story is left open-ended in dragon
ball super broly
implying we have yet to see just how
strong broly can truly become
some may think broly should be much
higher on this list but he lacks
adaptability
he may be a bottomless pit of raw power
but he's just not honed
still it's a bit scary to imagine what
he might be capable of
given the proper training and some
caring friends there's plenty of stuff i
want to teach him too if he's interested
few characters exhibit the raw power
that majin buu has aimed at humanity
this regenerating pink mass possesses a
unique ability to turn his enemies into
chocolate
and absorb their power by eating them
adding a layer of terror icing to an
extremely unpredictable villain
majin buu was created by a warlock many
years before the main characters were
born
upon release from his imprisonment he
showed that there is no controlling his
childlike emotions
his lack of control adds many challenges
to an already formidable enemy
no other character in all of dragon ball
has shown as many different forms and
transformations as majin buu
morphing numerous times based on his
emotional responses
and eating habits though his
regenerative ability combines with his
power level to create a seemingly
unbeatable foe buu is a slave to his
emotions
ego and reason play second fiddle to his
reactive persona
resulting in a lack of technique and
passion needed to rise up against new
challenges
it is for this reason that such an
impregnable character
finds himself at the bottom of the list
it goes without saying that the son of
the first super saiyan would inherit a
solid amount of power through genetics
alone
gohan has shown time and again in
moments of crisis that there is an
immense amount of power lying inside his
docile heart
his strongest aspects shine through in
his protective instincts
drawing power from a limitless well of
energy when seeing his loved ones in
danger
at times he displays a power beyond that
of super saiyan
surpassing even goku it is gohan who
while not delivering the final blow
ultimately defeats the bioandroid cell
when the rest of earth's heroes have
fallen despite all that power
gohan's sand fighting instincts are
tempered by some of his more human
attributes
the desire to fight and grow stronger
are of little interest to this gentle
soldier
his interests lie in raising a family
and studying to become a renowned
scholar
with training and a drive to surpass his
competitors there is no doubt that gohan
could become a fighter of extremely
potent power and prestige alas his
preference for a simple life
lowers this member of the endangered
saiyan race down near the bottom of the
list
oh sorry i didn't ask are you more of a
vanilla guy if so then take this one i'm
easy
no it's not a problem chocolate's fine
i'm a softy for soft-serve
uh yeah this stoic assassin emerged as a
fierce competitor in his battle with
goku in the tournament of power
known among universe 6 as the legendary
assassin hit possesses an extremely
unique and powerful ability in time skip
which allows him to manipulate time and
skip forward a tenth of a second
which is hugely significant once you
move as fast as the characters on this
list do
hit combines his time skip ability with
his phoenix eye fist
to focus his attacks into one point and
aim at his opponent's vital organs
given that the trenchcoat clad hitman is
also over a thousand years old
he also has a vast amount of experience
he can rapidly adapt
to his fighting situation shown in his
ability to improve his time skip for
even larger chunks of time
in his fight against goku somehow he's
figured out how to improve his fighting
move in the middle of this match without
any boost to his power
while his rare ability allows for a
large advantage once his opponents study
his moves
they're able to predict where he'll go
next and defend appropriately
this leaves something lacking in this
incredible fighter's raw base power
the primary antagonist in the dragon
ball series frieza
appears multiple times as goku's arch
nemesis
he plays a major part in the saiyan
timeline as the character responsible
for the destruction of their homeworld
the obliteration of the planet namek
personally killing vegeta's father
and has led multiple invasions of earth
the emperor of universe 7 possesses an
incredible knack for drawing upon
vast amounts of energy his strongest
original form
is buried beneath a series of
transformations in order to help his
body contain his incredible might
frieza is extremely hard to kill and is
so talented as a fighter that he
achieved his golden form with only four
months of training
his power is second only to his enormous
ego which
is damaged so badly by his defeat to
goku it takes him years of mental
training for him to regain his strength
the mark of a true villain shines
through and freezes cruelty via torture
and genocide
the freezer force did he really wipe out
his entire army just to make a point
should this tyrant be able to temper his
arrogance and psychopathic tendencies
he will no doubt rival the universe's
strongest heroes
the pride troopers of universe 11 are
led by the husky warrior known as toppo
despite his rotund stature the candidate
for the next god of destruction
is deceptively fast and shrouds all his
actions in an extra thick layer of
justice
his specialties in battle lie not only
in his energy blasts but in close
quarter combat via debilitating locks
and holds
while his base power level is already
crazy strong
once his energy surges displayed by a
menacing purple aura
it reveals toppo's true power enabling
an easy victory of frieza's golden form
while usually displaying respect to his
fellow fighters he also has a bit of a
temper which can disrupt his normally
level-headed fighting style
desperation causes toppo to abandon his
principles in the pursuit of victory
which
ultimately leads to his defeat at the
hands of vegeta
an infinite supply of anger courses
through the saiyan bloodline in the form
of prince vegeta originally destined to
rule his doomed home planet
the reluctant anti-heroes power levels
always seem to be just a step behind
earth's strongest occasionally crossing
into the mightiest of the dragon ball
pantheon through displays of pure
rage few are liked by the sardonic
warrior prince
and even fewer are as dedicated to the
achievement of ultimate power
vegeta's dedication to martial arts and
the cultivation of his qi
are unparalleled combined with his regal
bloodline
these characteristics make for one of
the most dominant fighters in the
universe
while he repeatedly says goku is his
mortal enemy his actions show respect
and acknowledgement in the competitive
drive supplied by his saiyan companion
once sent to earth in the form of an
enemy in search of the dragon balls
his disdain for kakarot is pacified by
his desire to pass him in terms of power
he repeatedly falls short in this
endeavor as his anger
tends to overwhelm him and cause him to
rush into dangerous situations without
analysis
an extraordinarily high opinion of
himself results in vegeta
underestimating his opponents and
charging in ill-prepared
his immense amount of pride calls forth
endless pools of power
and at other times serves as a
debilitating weakness
i don't care how powerful you are i will
be the one who defeats you and
claims a super dragon ball
regardless he continues to be one of
universe 7's strongest heroes
the backstory of this stoic fighter is
wrought with death and loneliness
jiren hasn't moved a muscle yet yeah i
know what i expect him to
that's kind of a schtick the whole stoic
thing
as a child jiren lost his parents and
his entire village to a villainous demon
who
in a later confrontation also killed his
master
this resulted in a lifetime of
dedication to strength and honor
and until he joined the pride soldiers
jiren spent a large portion of his life
alone in his training the most
impressive aspect of this burly fighter
lies in his little need for much
transformation to call forth
vast amounts of energy as he's able to
sustain his energy levels through
incredible displays of strength and
endurance
he is viewed as the most powerful
warrior in universe 11 and is the only
mortal
capable of defeating their god of
destruction in one of the most climactic
moments in dragon ball super
goku transforms into his most powerful
form yet
ultra instinct but even in this ultimate
form
jiren simply draws forth even more
energy to continue battling toe to toe
with the saiyan
most of the fighters in the universe use
transformations to temporarily multiply
their
power beyond what is normally
sustainable for their bodies
jiren employs a mostly defensive style
that forces his opponents to exhaust
themselves
allowing for his attacks to land with
devastating results
while jiren possesses a herculean amount
of power his life resulted in an almost
cold disposition
that leaves no room for emotion which
happens to be the greatest source of
strength for the series primary
protagonist
the dragon ball series begins with goku
as a child
teaming up with bulma in a hunt for the
mythical dragon balls
all these years later the lovable
defender of earth continues to grow in
strength while maintaining a gentle
disposition that seems to disarm
even the gods of destruction seemingly
devoid of any negative emotions
goku has ambitions that stem from his
desire to protect those he loves
it is in moments of despair when his
loss in battle would spell death for
those around him
that the saiyan draws forth epic new
levels of power to overwhelm his enemies
whether it be through a signature move
the kamehameha or by
channeling qi from nearby life forms to
form the almighty spirit bomb
the admirable hero always finds a way
goku was met with another moment of
desperation in the final minutes of the
tournament of power
with the losers of the tournament facing
the destruction of their universe
our favorite saiyan displays a fighting
form normally reserved for the gods in
ultra instinct
a transformation in which the mind
separates from the body
leaving it to operate on pure instinct
though others may seem stronger at first
goku has shown us repeatedly that few
can match the limitless well of energy
that flows through the cheery protector
of universe 7. this cat-like humanoid
shows a level of indifference to most
life-forms that could only be reserved
for an entity of cosmic power
beerus seems to harbor no ill will
towards any life-forms
merely annoyance at any disruptions in
his favorite activities
acting mostly as a mechanism of nature
as a god of destruction
he is served with the duty of
maintaining balance in universe 7
which he enacts through the decimation
of any planet that displeases him
the imposing entity has existed for
millions of years
which adds quite a bit of experience to
the gourmet loving god's remarkable
power
while goku seems to be evenly matched
with him at certain points
it is apparent that beerus did not come
close to unleashing his full potential
he is able to nullify the energy of most
mortals and can launch
devastating attacks with his sphere of
destruction and has a base power level
which needs no transformation
or amplification most mortals cower
before his fickle appetites
but there's someone who quite literally
schools him in terms of strength
and technique when we first meet this
lean aloof individual
it's not readily apparent that great
power lies behind his carefree smile
while beerus zips around the universe
imposing his will on
anyone who dares annoy him lee stands by
his side
appearing as no more than a gentle
companion complacent in running trivial
errands
as the story unwinds it becomes clearer
that the immortal angel possesses an
unfathomable amount of power when beerus
begins destroying worlds
after consuming wasabi whis knocks him
out with a single chop to the neck
in dragon ball super he appears to exert
little effort in a sparring session
against both goku and vegeta even going
as far as autographing the unwitting
saiyan's outfits in the middle of their
duo onslaught
whis has the ability to rewind time up
to three minutes without creating any
paradoxes or time loops
a necessary power when one's sole
responsibility is to mitigate the powers
of a god of destruction
despite all these abilities his
effortless displays of speed and
strength
compared with a pension for table
manners and a love for earth cuisine
there is no other being in universe 7
with as much power
which makes his serene disposition all
the more sensible
what need is there for any displays of
anxiety or negative emotion and nothing
in your realm of existence is capable of
causing you harm
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite powerful anime characters
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one